it was one of the worst floods in german
history
last july water swept through towns
lashing rain washing away the land
extreme weather bringing a european
superpower to its knees
so the water was
to the roof
one meter
higher than this wow
a year on martin's home is still drying
out
he says there was no warning for this he
could only watch as water inundated the
care home opposite killing 12.
we heard one of the
people living in this building
crying
help help me and he was holding on a
tree or on the
window
was the only one who survived this in
the
basement
the scars of the storm are still visible
in some streets no building was left
untouched
businesses have closed people moved away
this is the richest country in europe
and yet a year on some communities are
just shells of what they were homes
completely devastated here houses
utterly destroyed and people here are
petrified of being forgotten and are
wondering will they be protected
in the future
on the edge of towns temporary villages
house the victims this is kitchen this
is our kitchen
anya and rayna are living in a container
their home is still unsafe
and is terrified of heavy rain
it's still really hard
30 billion euros of damage done
overnight the local wine industry took a
huge hit
peter's selling flood-soaked bottles to
raise money
yeah i think so the climate change is a
very big problem and so we must protect
us it was not high water it was a
tsunami it was a big wave and destroy
everything in this valley
as communities try to rebuild
experts say this could happen again
germany is not prepared at all right now
such kind of events could happen more
often and even more intense because
we're just at the beginning of climate
change
i'm prepared and under-equipped
germany's government now has a new
disaster plan but climate change pushed
this country to its limits and the next
test could be even more brutal siobhan
robbins sky news germany